are you husband material or are you just
a fling oh boy
are you real oh say that yeah I guess if
you see see boy oh boy what kind of boy
are you would we would we pick you but
before we even roll into that like
that's both epic of the day it's hot
guys versus husbands like we you know I
feel like this is a big marry a hot guy
yeah you can I did but but but there's I
feel like it's kind of similar for guys
like well how some hot guys say like oh
that girl's hot but I wouldn't
necessarily date her and I think girls
kind of have a similar thing but before
we roll into this I want to talk about
something really important that I just
realized all right I need you guys to
picture this you're 12 years old you're
going over to your friend's house just
pretend to have friends Nikki okay
you're 12 years old
you're you're your kid your boy you're
going to your friend's house Oh am i if
you love going to your friend's house
because he's got a hot mom in that mom I
just realized the MILF of milk because
is 12 he's well right so all of these
all of his friends are coming over it
morning yeah they're looking at tip like
you're literally literally the milf of
milk you know like we walk in this
morning and then they're all saying that
and I'm like nah mean their friend's
moms are hot too like a we're all like
we just no no this is another great okay
so I think we talked about this before
at least I've said it and I think some
people attacked on to where I mentioned
there's a period of the month
when I'm ovulating right now wait for me
yes right now this moment right now is
horny we're we are included sobbing
we're literally
in heat in this time I feel like I get I
get really attracted to certain guys but
I wouldn't want to like date them I
wouldn't want to marry that Roo I just
want to like run through like what are
those qualities like what is that what
does that look like
I mean wait do you guys have like a
celebrity crush oh I got some celebrity
crushes that's that's how my love for
Jason Momoa like sprouted during an
ovulation was not the type of guy that I
would actually want to marry sure he
does see I'm just talking about
appearances wise like he's like too buff
like too big likes too much who can't
picture him holding your babies I mean
maybe but no like I don't know just like
physically speaking he's not the type of
guy that I would want to marry like I
love you don't see him standing next to
you in your wedding photos yeah oh god
yeah me either steal the show yeah he's
too high like he's too big he's so much
think there's just too much going on I
don't want to go out in public with you
flipping that hair around like the
entire sphere like no and he like orders
me a shot and slice sounds like here you
go baby I'd be like get out yeah like
for me I don't know like the the whole
like husband vibe which is funny because
Casey's totally this but like the Joseph
gordon-levitt and like the Justin
Timberlake like NSYNC like more like
boyish like I that's the kind of guy
that I married
I like the boys more sweet did any of
you guys watch the love is blind oh my
god I'm on episode like five right now
okay like they're in Cancun or wherever
but like yeah no spoilers yeah oh but
husband material
Cameron Reid Hamilton oh yeah same oh
yes he's like the nerd but he's like a
quiet sweet blindest guy but he's like
present right
you like present oh yes absolutely I
married the black girl yes yes yes yes
he looks at her like she's a doll there
was like I need to be looked at I feel
like Steve looks like something does
yeah yeah like I
dude he I was imagining this I was like
bro if he was in his little his little
science lab cooking up them little robot
I'm over in the marketing department on
my own [ __ ] that guy
she had never dated a white dude before
you'd never guess I was like really
surprised she was like I didn't know if
he was Puerto Rican Latino black white I
didn't know he had a nappy way and it
was like a big deal for her I haven't
seen the end yet like they meet the
families or anything like yeah no
spoilers no spots the same territory of
like kind of like husband material look
bottom like well we'll keep going in
this but I already see the bottom line
here if you're too hot we can't marry ya
too intimidating can I say teacher that
I raise my hand I don't know why I
wouldn't we're talking about ovulating
first of all like if it's been more than
a few weeks that I haven't gotten laid
like anything that walks by I'm like I
don't know [ __ ] but I've noticed are you
currently just got past it okay yeah
I've noticed when I'm ovulating the
types of guys I'm attracted to are kind
of pudgy Oh dad buds yeah I don't know
why it's like I've never I don't have
talked about this before I've never
really like been super physically
attracted right off the bat to people
like everyone kind of looks like a blob
until they make me laugh but if we're
just going off physical appearances dad
bods make me wet make me wet Jesus yeah
do they represent you security to you I
don't know cuddly yeah it's like cuddly
it's like oh he could [ __ ] me and then
we could cuddle really well I want you
to be like snap my nose off with your
abs but they look big to like they're
big like they're tall pudgy dude so like
we're so like right
so edgy but I think my top three
celebrities are Eminem Chris Pratt and
Ryan Gosling but I think Steve as a
combination of those three guys think
about it
Eminem Chris Pratt I'm hoping that he'll
learn to rap eventually oh my god not
even close from the Midwest he's funny
Craig Stokes yeah he does he's got bars
Steve green has bars dude my my Oh as of
late my ultimate fantasy right now is
Robert Pattinson my light phase like
after that so I am now you know what
yeah oh yes he [ __ ] idiot
oh me too I already started putting out
calls so I could get into the premiere
absolutely like I needed me I want to go
no I
this person Paul Batman's the hottest
superhero yes or no yes because Superman
he's hot but he's not cocky enough so
it's like he's too nice you know BAM in
kind of cocky but also hot iron man also
also cocky both rich with you I think
Batman for me resembles a little bit
more of a dark brooding energy yeah and
like that's what I want ya to ram into
me as a dark dark brooding inner join
his Batmobile in my Batcave
[Laughter]
sorry guys I'm Superman girl he's so
romantic
Oh exactly wait there for my Mara I'm
more of a joker
okay that's true we talk about like like
hot guys versus house husbands like
honestly okay this is gonna sound dumb
but like I I can't think of anyone else
this is not like this person is not
always on the top of my mind but the
epitome of I will [ __ ] you but I won't
marry you is like g-eazy Oh a picture of
a joker put it on his lipstick in the
mirror and then bows like I'm gonna [ __ ]
like the mischief factor but then second
in line would be Batman just because
like he's rich ever like the like bad
boy type like we've all made my guys
sure I said I like Eminem the Joker is
just a little bit too messy for me yeah
why are we going back to the Joker I
said now you put pictures and all of
them I like Mark Wahlberg he's a bad boy
yes I was thinking Obama is not a bad do
it he is man
it's a submission when he was a teenager
which people forgot about turn off for
me what's his song remember in the
nineties years of rappers it was so
brief oh yeah the Marky Mark yeah that I
don't know like physical alone like
despite his past which is a huge turnoff
but like if I was just to look at him
physically what about his passes that
turned off well he like like I did some
digging on like celebrities who did
[ __ ] up [ __ ] that people forgot about
and he like beat a Vietnamese guy just
for being nice but they've since made
amends and he apologized if Vietnamese
man was like it's okay it's cool I've
moved on maybe he got paid off I don't
know but yeah that was always like Mark
Wahlberg because of how he got with his
wife I always thought it was so sweet
how'd he get with his wife because she
was like a waitress he was already sent
like a celebrity and stuff she was a
waitress and then like they just
connected and
like that's so cute he didn't have to
marry someone famous oh that is cute
yeah I wonder if she was a fan he beat
up a Vietnamese me that's crazy I've
never heard that before social media so
you couldn't get cancelled or anything
like that it popped in my head I was
like oh yeah I learned that fact about
it you know what okay here's another one
that got me just really really got it
going okay
early 2000s Johnny Depp early 2000s when
he said no it was before that it was
when he was just hot and just about
really like pre him being like a pirate
I can see that Peter Pan movie let me I
need been better those need to see a
photo photo even better though I mean
nineties Leonardo Oh be still my beating
heart what I really enjoyed a dream that
I oh my I wish I could go back to this
dream so I once had a dream not learn
how to new that I can't speak 90s Brad
Pitt my dream bride who was coming on to
me and I was just like no I'm married
and then I woke up and I'm like dude
I've come in your dream always too
[ __ ] loyal in my day give me chicken
so hair day when I wake up you are cuz
you've mentioned this before it's so mad
getting hit on people keep trying to go
into Inception to [ __ ] who you last
night just last night it was another guy
I don't even know this this guy doesn't
exist but he was so hot he was coming on
to me and I was like no I'm married I'm
married
that's the allure in the dream too that
happened to me with Leo DiCaprio he
showed up in three of my dreams tricking
me into going on dates with him because
I was like I have a boyfriend
no he's nobody it's a business dinner
and I was like okay you didn't meet him
in person
you guys are actors then he came into my
work it's like after those hungry dreams
I'm like he's [ __ ] he's talking I
thought you were just
Trinity came in me he looked with his
piercing blue eyes straight in my soul
and he knew he was in my dreams and then
inception came out like two months later
Oh crazy that was based on me dude if I
had a dream where one of them was trying
to sleep with me I am like I turn it
down or just didn't go through I would
force myself back to sleep like I tried
even fell asleep and I had a dream about
something else that was so dumb I'm like
damn it where's Brad Pitt a waste I got
one for you guys okay Tom Hardy is my
he's Tom Hardy have you seen what's that
movie lawless no I haven't seen that Oh
Oh give it to me Tom Bronson the one the
Bronson one where he played like two
guys he was super hot that one
okay so the only reason why I went to
the theaters with TIFF and case and
Isaac to watch venom the movie Tom Hardy
was the leading but in that I hated him
in that role so I was very disappointed
but he was really good in definitely
came out then yeah I remember seeing
your trailer for it over and over again
and then I just never heard about it
coming out in 2018 the song came out
drop kamikaze if you wanna check me
September 2008 ta fetch and that was for
the soundtrack to venom you know came up
with once I saw him in the very first
movie I saw him in Michael B Jordan I
know Gina's not here he's got Superman
I'm not trying to swoop it's just listen
I saw it wasn't validation and I was
like oh my god swoon yes station oh it's
a really good movie it's actually based
on a true story where this guy from like
Oakland you should check it out it's
really good but he plays them the lead
character and when I saw him and he ends
up like dying spoiler alert but it's
true story he ends up dying at the end
and I was like Michael B Jordan because
I really believed it well Leo died
Titanic and that broke my heart okay so
I was just thinking about this I was
thinking like who would I actually marry
like celebrity wise like how like a
husband status but Chris Pratt would be
a good one
mine would be wait don't make fun of me
like - the drinking problem
Jimmy Fallon yeah explain we're not
judging are you kidding me Tonight Show
or whatever he's on yeah so cringy bad
no it's because he's been drinking or he
needs a drink like he's got some [ __ ]
up things that I could I could get
turned off and that is husband material
you got to be a little broken so I can
pick you up and fix you and he's rich
right I was I mean whack when like when
I fell in love with Jimmy Fallon I was
like ya know he was on SNL but I didn't
have a baby bunny or anyone that could
take care of me so it was more so I just
like I was eight and I was like I love
this right what about him he's just
funny he's funny and like he that's not
enough to be husband he's funny he's a
seven I was like that about Adam Sandler
very similar see yeah exactly I was like
because you guys are still in Hawkeye
mode we're back at house we're back in
marriage mode hold on here's something
that I wanna show my brain for me I
cannot marry you if you're above a knee
like an eight is like the top like the
limit like I can't I can't marry an 9 or
10 are you guys kidding me you guys
could I don't know if they're funny
usually nine songs aren't funny I never
really like look at a guy and be like
you're this I don't know
no instant ends usually didn't have to
develop a really deep sense of humor to
get by so they're typically not funny
but if they were like an ugly duckling
such as Chris Pratt they did develop
that yeah came and then and then I'm
like mm-hmm
yeah it's ring on it's a sense of sir
well didn't wait word all of us have
kind of Lee yes you will just said she
but just felt like she wasn't hot she
like she was hot but she felt like she
wasn't same for you you were high except
on one picture that one picture was bad
but the restaurant the rest of the
pictures are pretty good always been hot
you know you're pregnant you were like
normal wait it'll just look like I had a
basketball yeah after a burrito
I think wait makes you ugly or not no I
mean like it's really good even when she
like got plumped out which plummeted or
something I'm not like if Jess you need
a leave girl pummeled yeah well she did
get pummeled to get pregnant yeah I did
yes well she always had that glowing
smile I needed to get my teeth fixed so
I never had this beautiful smile so I
always wanted a nice smile in high
school but instead I had a mouth full of
braces because I didn't have a nice
smile yet you know why to my mouth they
had to put metal in my mouth that put
rubber bands in there all kinds of crazy
stuff painful I wish it was as easy as
it is now to get a nice smile how do we
get it now you could put on candid clear
aligners they're comfortable removable
and totally invisible so you can
transform your smile without anyone
noticing a thing unlike my dumbass put
like clear rubber bands on you tried
clear braces with clear rubber bands in
the rubber bands it just turns yellow
like you're nasty
yeah was bad plus with with Candide you
never have to set foot in a doctor's
office or waiting room your treatment is
prescribed and monitored remotely by a
licensed orthodontist and unlike other
companies candid only works with
orthodontists never general dentists
with other remote clear aligner options
you may never hear from a doctor at all
as you go through the treatment that
means her treatment will be designed by
an expert in tooth with candid and they
do it in just six months which is okay
if you're gonna get married I repent and
the worst part about going to a doctor
for clear aligners is they scan you and
then it takes
six weeks to get your trays can't have
everything faster you're in control of
it you're in and out done in six months
simplest freest way to get started and
it works so are you ready to take the
first step towards the straighter teeth
I am for a limited time you could get
started with $75 off by using code mood
at Candide koat.com / mood
that's candid co.com / mood use code
mood for $75 off candid koat.com / mood
code mood you know what else you should
fix after you fix your teeth what you
should fix your closet yeah weird it's
fix okay
you can what is that fix your closet
it's a subscription service but you
don't have to get it every single week
you can actually do on demand orders as
well which I did that I like that for
seasonal yes so you go online you
describe your style through a series of
little quizzes and you can select yes I
like these clothes no I don't like these
clothes please help me shop cuz I don't
have time to shop exactly they'll just
deliver you some clothes right to your
front door I know you could just try
them based on your style home yes based
on your style stitch fix is an online
personal styling service that delivers
your favorite clothing shoes and
accessories directly to you have the
brands you know and love plus exclusive
styles you won't find elsewhere everyone
can look their best they have solutions
for women men and kids all over the US
and now even in the UK so get started
today at stitch fix com / mood and get
an extra 25% off when you keep
everything in your box
that's stitch fix calm / mood again that
stitch fix calm / mood so what are we
talking about now hot guys our marriage
hmm I want to know Linda who's who is
whose husband material or weight
actually while we're having this
conversation I'm wondering if is there
really that much of a line between what
we would date and what we would it looks
wise it's totally like irrelevant I
think when you when you're gonna decide
who you want to marry I mean not totally
irrelevant but mostly irrelevant I'm a
sapiosexual that's what I learned is
that like yeah I have to be stimulated
either by
intelligent conversation or by humor in
order to see that person as attractive
as physically attractive as cool why
what is it called when I need to feel
protected and that makes me really hot I
don't I don't know baby see that's true
because I was trying it like on my way
over here because I knew we're gonna
talk about this a bit like for this
episode I started thinking about like my
track record with guys and from starting
from like my very first crush when I was
a little girl and moving all the way up
and also like the father figures in my
life because you know that influences
what you're attracted to so I started
thinking about all that and I'm like man
I'm all over the place because there are
certain guys that are I'm really
attracted to that are like really like
rugged and manly and like adventurous
and very like dangerous but like will be
very protective and then there's like
the other side of the spectrum where
it's like a guy that's like really like
boyish and like like romantic and really
loving and yeah and very like
sophisticated and so I'm all over the
place yeah nothing like that - I'm all
over the place physically but
personality-wise very similar in each
guy like I've dated super short super
tall colors of the rainbow twill not
that many colors of the rainbow but as
many as I could in Santa Barbara I think
I've noticed because I was talking to my
other friends and yes I'm sorry you guys
I have some friends now whatever she got
a text the other day and I saw her phone
call I said who is Kelsey her name's not
Kelsey by the way she just pulled that
out of their butt so they noticed cuz I
was showing them like going through this
dating app and I was showing them like
oh this guy's cute this guy's cute this
guy's cute and then they were like dude
you like the same guy like they all even
say that you like guys like you have
sent in the chat I'm like these are all
like the same like maybe they'll be a
little different shade
what if they all look like Joe just
Okawa nobody no I'm not even close sorry
dragon what does your dad look like I
could have never dad yeah I don't know I
mean I had a right describe my dad looks
like he's tall and thin I feel like most
of the guys you pick your tall and then
they are yeah well I never dated tall
and thin guys really before because no
like I previously I was dating like a
lot of guys a little bit shorter yeah
okay maybe they were taller but more
built more muscular but now I've been
more now I've been more attracted to
like tall and maybe a little bit more
lanky like I don't necessarily go for
that athletic body type that I liked in
my 20s so I'm going a little bit more
kind of like TIFF was saying maybe a
little more intellectual a little bit
more bookie yeah a bit more book like
library
I'm not trick when Steve and I first
started dating he was tall and lanky
with glasses he was like super nerd
looking and then he like now he's all
bulky yeah he like gained weight and
then he now he's been working out and
Sonu has muscles like saying last week
during JK news I forgot what he was
doing I think it was Tim that was like
oh let me see that bicep or something in
the hands of doing this and you could
see like easy has bicep oh wow pecs I'm
like he's actually been working out
there's the dad bod is getting removed
you're like do you like I do actually
I'm surprisingly I think that's why I
like it because it's still Steve and
he's like very attractive with the humor
and then the muscles are like an added
bonus now and I picture him paintings is
pretty bit yeah he's Chris prating me oh
dude I'm such a sucker for when a guy
takes his arm and puts it behind the
head
me too oh it's such a sucker okay you
like the armpit huh oh I do like the arm
with the way the sleeve had you know I
like about this is the lats I like to
see a nice full settle ass but actually
I'm I'm straying away from from that
athletic body type now do you guys know
who Tom Ellis is no is he a singer he's
a pastor have you seen the show Lucifer
no oh yeah I know exactly who suffer and
the show on FX hey I keep wanting him to
be attractive and then he
doesn't do it oh he's doing it for me
the only reason I sat through that whole
damn series was because of Tom Ellis and
then I followed him on Instagram and I
was like he has a wife and this cute
little family disgusting I love him you
know
well you know what I think my purse my
underlying like when I think about every
guy I've dated all very very different
all colors of the rainbow all different
probably personalities you know and I
think every single one of them really
liked me so I always felt very valued
like incredibly I felt like like they
needed me like to an extent like you
know some of them were a little more
independent but I never felt like oh you
know he could walk away from this
relationship and be totally okay like I
always felt very loved and very valued
and then I think sometimes when we have
these incredibly successful or
incredibly hot guys sometimes they may
treat us or we might by default start to
feel like we're not very valued whereas
maybe with like certain guys we do well
is that within yourself though like it's
like you're deciding how valued you are
or is it like literally their actions
are kind of they're just dude they're I
mean it's just not a good part to
because then I could match those because
I'm like how someone can make you feel
important I think it all boils down to
feeling important in that person's life
right but a very charming man can make
you feel important when you're not at
all yeah what you're not important know
what I mean like to him like there's
there's players that are so charming
that's not necessarily well they like
those people because I've dated one of
those that made me feel important when
he was speaking but then the actions
didn't back it up and when I was yeah
yeah I'm the opposite of you were like
almost every guy that I dated before
made me work for it where like I felt
less then all the time and I think I had
to fix my own daddy issues before I
actually attracted a healthy
relationship because that's when it
started for me when I was like I don't
go to a therapist you know what I do
miss oh I do love and I do miss a little
[ __ ] boy sometimes we're known to make
me work for it make me feel like I'm
less than make me feel like a piece of
[ __ ]
go and change stop turning me on I don't
did you help me every now and then to
get wrapped up in a fuck-boy but not all
the time now I would play the [ __ ] boy
game differently than I would now
because I would play their game back Sam
I will play the game like how you play
the game Jess doesn't play the game Jess
shows up just is the game and says I'll
take that and I don't want to play
anymore that's it and I never got to I
never got to experience you know hanging
out with [ __ ] boys are like you know
dating [ __ ] boys and like not caring
yeah I never got to not care I always
from the very beginning yeah I think
sometimes like I'll not care for a
series of weeks and then eventually I'm
like oh but I do care now because I had
to win and I didn't win so now I get all
I want I like I literally really almost
like wish I could go ladies
if you are in your early 20s right now
find a [ __ ] boy and just don't don't
care just have fun with it let it be fun
I've never easier said than done for a
twenty year olds into little they're so
emotionally nobody ever told us to just
go have fun like our generation like
seeing like the like what suck brain
just farted but you know like the hose
and stuff yeah like it's always oh okay
the hose this is what's happening in my
brain okay last night I had a
conversation with Isaac and he acted a
little nuts of [ __ ] hoes no listen he
accidentally he created remember the
shots that I sent oh yeah so it's like
lime juice with the Hien and he was
trying to think of a name for for this
shot and he came up with thought because
it Oh like like Tajin shot but then he
was like oh wait no that means something
else he knows what it is and I was like
do you know what it stands for it means
like that hoe over there he was like
he's like gardening tool so then he was
like what does ho mean though I'm like
well I mean you take a whole like for
the gardening tool he's like no no the
other one and then I'm like well usually
it's referred to a girl that sleeps
around with a lot of guys but you know
that's kind of sexist because guys sleep
with a lot of girls but they don't
really get called ho hos called a play
yeah yeah that's exactly what he said
he's like they get called a play
and then I'm like positive it has a
pocket connotation to it rather than for
the girls like a ho is a negative thing
it's just a nail in the coffin yeah yeah
so then um I was like where are you
going with this and I was like you know
what yeah teach him that I think my hope
is was exactly the right amount of
satisfying well I was like I ate a good
meal and then I'm like ready to settle
down yeah dude you had I feel like you
had like the dream hoping that horny
Nick like I feel like I understand horny
Nicky like I never got to be horny both
Oh true I want to be horny bones yes
yeah anything goes south with your
current relationship which I hope it
doesn't because I love your current
relationship but if it ever does you
then you could have third wind I think
yeah because I was in a series of a lot
of relationships so I had like the young
girl who faced the mid to late 20s ho
phase and now is my early to mid-30s
hopeful what are they all different yes
this whole phase was played this is the
one over so that I feel like Brice is
actually on edge the whole time and like
I'm all about it or we can't it's a
great got my dick sucking technique down
on this whole fee honestly you know how
to [ __ ] yeah you know like it's so much
better than just getting pummeled by
guys in college like it's way different
getting pummeled yeah today I'm just
thinking about Tom Hardy or Tom a little
humbling me and I'm thinking about like
nineteen-year-old college phase where
you're just [ __ ] in a dorm room and
everyone knows about it but then like
your 30s whole phase is like fun flirty
next yeah you get to swipe on tender
you're like yeah I'd [ __ ] him then you
guys go meet up for a drink you talk a
little bit and then in 45 minutes you
decide do we keep talking or do we go
home fine nobody ever told us yeah don't
settle down when I have my own
studio in Hollywood it was this cute ass
little studio with a brick wall like
exposed brick and it was all my no
roommates and I was like 26 so it was
like old enough that like you could go
out for a drink and then like have a
little fun first and then decide if you
want to go back home but like young
enough that you're like hey Felix
that's the phase that you had like the
TV show in the movies like the young
yeah mid-twenties like entrepreneurs
yeah but I think I think the best part
about it was that I didn't plan it I
really wanted to stay in my serious
relationship and he [ __ ] it up and
then I was like well I don't care about
anybody else so I guess I'll just go
have fun yeah dude I feel like God I get
so tired of like realizing that people
should have told me certain things but
no one ever told you how fun it would be
to be single in your 30s like Jess you
live in the dream [ __ ] you're in Los
Angeles single hot famous like you do
you're you're doing pretty well you
gotta acknowledge it maybe not
necessarily famous but you know what I
mean you know yeah it's good and bad
like some days it's good because right
I'm like okay picture this
mmm for some reason we were both but
Nick it just came into my head but that
summer I was going you would know we
were both I thought that too but then I
loved shaggy so it's it's like 9 p.m.
it's dark outside there's city lights it
just rained the streets are a little bit
wet there's like a little bit of
romantic there's a little bit of a
saxophone music plays a references go
for some reason you're at a restaurant
right there's candles all around there's
a beautiful little lighting and maybe
even there's mason jars with lights
inside of them and some flowers or in a
hipster town gentrified neighborhood
yeah there's some library books lined up
along this bar you're like oh this is
cute and a little swanky and everyone
thinks that they're sophisticated and
weirdest at this bar or Prohibition era
mixology bar there's a guy in front of
you and he's just looking at your lip
and then that your eyes did this happen
to you
maybe you can't picture this he's an
engineer
oh he's smart and you guys start talking
about books you've read and and like you
know there's three there's actually
conversation if I can turn the page
become a wreck she's a grey love it so
that can go so now you as a 32 year old
woman can decide where does this go you
a [ __ ] this man really hard in the back
of an uber which is really not a pro so
it is the uber driver their exit his
vehicle he's taking you to your Ober to
drop you off but before you get home you
got to hurry up and bang it out because
maybe I don't want to see this engineer
maybe he is an amazing guy but maybe you
know what I just want to bang him in up
but then choose your own adventure part
- this is option B it should be as you
don't have sex with me option C as you
go to his place yes see he has a
sprawling apartment with
floor-to-ceiling windows real plantation
is a clean town oh no no okay Korea tech
C D ANC it's in West Hollywood somewhere
and a cute little swanky you know
neighborhood and then or you know
whatever you know it's choose your own
adventure in your 30s later you get some
marry the guy we got a you got a no
we're not really there that's a
different well by the series but when
you're in your 20s right like you're at
a college party you're drinking out of a
Red Solo Cup yeah and then a dumbass
comes up to you and you wind up sucking
him off in a toilet
wow that's a little different
I'm just so always tell stories ever
done justice history stall with a little
bit of come on your face and he's
washing his hands like piss all around
you because the frat house is dirty you
may have a missed call from your mom or
seven yeah you know why and I feel like
- like I can't believe that there's a
stigma we're supposed to settle down in
our 20s or so because your 20s you're
just like panic it's just sheer a hand
of your life together yet yeah it's like
at 20 you think all right I got this
cool great and it like do you think it's
gonna be so much fun I'm almost 21 then
when you hit 21 and you have like your
first drink you're like well this is it
and then you're like no you're like damn
how am I gonna be able to afford these
drinks these are expensive like 21 to 29
is just different levels of panic and I
put them in threes like 21 through like
24 4 yeah yeah and then 24 to 26 is a
whole another time manic and then well
actually to 27 and then 27 to 30 30 dude
it's yeah they're all different types of
panic Nicki you look like you're having
flashbacks I actually as much as you say
that jess is living the dream 30s single
I feel like I feel like emotionally yes
like being in a toxic relationship
versus being single and happy and like
free absolutely but I feel like I am
very happy with being married in my 30s
yeah I I got married at 30 like was
single all through I mean was single and
a day throughout my 20s but I feel like
that's he's the perfect combination of
what I'm attracted to physically and
marriage material which i think is that
is what I would want to settle down I
mean obviously I think like having a
partner that is actually valuable that
adds to your life yeah away from me like
all of those things are preferable to
just being single and balancing that
other thing I think the bottom line is
people need to learn how to develop
being happy alone without somebody
without being dependent on someone else
giving them value or showing them their
love once you are able to make your own
self happy
anyone that you settled with should be
enhancing that they should not take away
from that they should not be the one
that gives you that they should just be
enhancing what you already have and then
vice versa
and your and like if you don't
understand that such as myself you will
like continue this pattern of getting
into relationships that don't like ya
don't fulfill it because you need to
fulfill yourself if you know the
baseline of what you feel like when
you're fully fulfilled then you'll start
to notice people that actually elevate
you yeah but if you don't have that
skill set if you don't have that feeling
in yourself then you're just gonna go
for anything that will give you
attention right like and that's right
that's what I did for the majority any
learn how to set boundaries you know
what makes you happy you know what you
won't put up with you know what is
taking away from you you have a better
gauge on like what is taken away from
that happiness and so you're a lot more
just matter-of-fact like nope that's not
okay with me this is not okay with me
yeah and I feel like communication gets
enhanced that way and that's when you
get into a healthy relationship you're
like I could do this forever it's kind
of like husband material will draw
itself to you when you're ready for it
because you don't need boys yeah formula
because then if not it ends up happening
where you get into a serious
relationship where now you're trying to
figure all this out while being
committed to someone else and it's just
a lot harder guys don't do that yeah
really really really hard you know while
you're working on yourself I think the
best thing to do is get into fitness
[Music]
fitness and in 2020 the best way to do
fitness is out of your own home with a
subscription service like open fit open
fit takes all the complexity out of
losing weight and getting fit it's a
brand new super simple streaming service
that allows you to work out from the
comfort of your living room yeah that's
what I'm talking about 2020 Fitness
y'all at my apartment gym using open fit
on their tablets yes sis bar a Pilates
cardio strength yoga even guys walking
sessions absolutely walk slower walk
faster run run
run they got you they got you this is
the future is now why are you leaving
your house let just work out from home
don't pay for a trainer in real life
don't yes beyond don't pay for a trainer
in real life you can sculpt your body
out of the convenience in your home home
look hot and get yourself ready for your
new husband it's affordable and
accessible and you get exactly what you
pull in put in just commit and you'll
see results in just 30 days
so we tried open fit and actually I
mostly I like the ease of use with it
just being able to turn it all in there
15 minute sessions or they have longer
sessions as well and you can actually
get a personalized journey for me I'm a
little bit lazy I don't want to do I
want I want to do cardio look I don't
want to depart I want to do what feels
good but also kind of learning an
impression on my body and you can do
that too with a personalized workout so
I get it that's right open fit has
changed the way that we workout and by
texting our code mood to 50 50 50 you
can join me on a fitness journey
personalized for you so right now during
the open fit 14 day challenge our
listeners can get a special extended 14
day that's two weeks membership of open
fit when you text mood to 50 50 50 you
will get full access to open fit all the
workouts even the nutrition information
totally free so you can just text mood
to 50 50 55 0 5 0 5 0 that's right
but by the way standard data and
messaging rates may apply oh you know
what else you could do at home what you
can talk to someone and get some actual
like personalized therapy I ain't even
got a Lee watch big moon you don't have
to leave your home yeah so with talk
space it's an online therapy and it is
the most convenient and affordable way
to make lasting change in your life with
the support of a licensed therapist so
you can send your licensed therapist a
text audio picture or video message from
your phone or your computer whenever you
want and there you will be scheduling
appointments with them so you can
actually talk on the phone if that's
what you prefer
no I like about it is that like even if
you have something that comes up without
an appointment like you can talk to
someone right away because sometimes
with anxiety issues or depression issues
I'll have an episode or something happen
where it's happening right now but my
appointments not till Friday but I need
help right now and you can actually
message them right away and you get
people responding you to you right away
you can see responds to you within two
hours or something yeah like super
quickly super quick responses and they
are trained in over 40 specialties so if
you have something very specific you
want to work on they will find someone
for you because talk space matches you
with a licensed therapist so many people
think that therapy is just about having
your dreams analyzed or digging into
painful memories which can be powerful
but it's also a great tool for
developing coping skills dealing with
stress and getting the accountability
you need to achieve your goals the
bottom line is life can be hard and talk
space wants to give more of us the
support we need at a price we can afford
as a listener of this podcast you can
get $100 off your first month on talk
space to match with your perfect
therapist go to talk space calm or
download the app make sure to use the
code mood to get $100 off your first
month and show your support for the show
that's mood and talk space calm um I I'm
kind of I'm kind of like it's trying to
think now like I'm wondering if the type
of person that I would want to be with
is gonna change at 40 now oh I think
yeah yeah I think your taste buds do you
ever do did any of you guys have this
experience where like when I was like 22
22 3 I looked at men like 30-year old
men and they look like a different
species I was like you like I'm gonna
end up marrying a man like somewhere
that like I've said
man I'm still attracted to like with
boys yeah like those like ish yeah cuz
now I look at the new boy like teens
alike those are children those are
little boys though yeah yeah literally
don't win the flip switched I guess when
people my age switched yeah I think it's
when like people my age started looking
more like men or something but now I
yeah I definitely think older men or
attract I feel that I think the two guys
that I listed Tom Hardy and Tom Ellis
are in their 40s and I never would yeah
like I never thought oh yeah never
thought that would have 40 year old guys
yeah 40
I can't salt and pepper in their hair
I'm like woo I love a little salt and
pepper now but I definitely I'm starting
to become more attracted to older men
like men yes I need a Maine little curl
with it get a little coarse right Tom
buy some papa gray on neck chest that's
what I need another yet really no with
salt and pepper I'm not there really
salt everywhere like a real salt and
pepper no like um so for me I found the
gray hair for the first time a few
months ago and I was like what am and
then I have found some in Casey's and
I'm like no I'm not ready for this oh
dude it's happening it's happening you
know what I like I as I get older
okay so there was a guy that I was
dating at one time it was the the Mormon
guy that when I came to his house
another girl showed up oh he was Mormon
I didn't know he was more yeah he was an
ex-mormon and he like left the church at
like 18 or so but when we went out on
our first date okay
oh my god hon I have to describe this
guy do you okay it's like other than
like the Edie and everything like super
hot wait what use huh you didn't
erectile dysfunction
oh yeah
so so I go on this date I go on this
date with John when we matched he's 34
his photo was late how old were you I
was this was two years ago so I was 26
okay and he was 34 that's a good that's
a good little different that's a good
little difference but I feel like that's
as far as you can stretch it like 24
then 35 just wouldn't like no he
shouldn't have done this anyway so we go
so his date was a profile picture was
kind of like I met him on tender and it
was this like kind of business suit
thing whatever so we go out he takes me
to this restaurant and the bartender the
bartender was Spanish and he just a
white dude too started speaking fluent
Spanish and I was just first of all like
this is [ __ ] hot yeah what you're
doing right here it's doing something
from me yes do that's how I was like
when I found out Casey made Cantonese
and I'm like accent or open my legs
every time yeah like honestly truly so
he does not and then he tells me like he
was the executive of this very well very
well-known company he was like a high
executive he was a team manager of like
over a hundred and forty people that
worked in like one office yeah and I
said what I was like what's the hardest
part of your job and he was like well I
mean you know hiring people it's always
a good time but firing people is
probably the hardest thing and he was
telling me about how he has to fire
people every day he took off like his
business jacket and I was like where are
my clothes you're like clothes mills I
want to get fired and then like
something about like the fluent Spanish
really got me but since he like wasn't
his native language yeah just that he
was so like cultured and like had some
more like 18 she was more seasoned like
that was so sexy to me like yo guys huh
be material for sure almost too much of
if you're in your 20s right now as a guy
pick up a talent a skill something
you're passionate about like that's
[ __ ] hot like to me it really really
is for sure for sure pick up pick up a
fake accent cuz that'll work on me wait
every accent though just we have fire
some off right okay yeah put it in me
[ __ ]
a venomous one I'm into it I'll do the
Vietnamese I'll take the gonna do a
Filipino one do you mind you this guy
that's a Japanese accent oh wow
she knows Japanese oh dude yeah one time
when we were at some we were at we were
at a crazy happen it's this restaurant
that I always go to I take just there
and like the whole style everyone's
Japanese and Jess or just order some
food and then she was like also can I
have the cookie and he's like they just
start going off in full-on Japanese this
way and the he walks away he's rock
[ __ ] hard and I was a judge how did
you just like that's the only word that
I can say that's the only thing I can
say but he was all about it I feel like
that's attractive for women to like for
a guy if they're dating a woman and
she's like cultured oh yeah not for
anyone yeah anyone pick up a passion
people I need I need to leave the
country should explore maybe just
learning how to cook like things from
different countries I make some pretty
good shakshuka what is this shuka north
african egg dish oh yeah it's very like
quail eggs or something sounds fancy
just eggs and tomatoes then just a
little egg into me next time I make
exit' tomatoes would you like some
shakshuka
it really is Nikki when the [ __ ] are you
ever making eggs and tomatoes never and
my boyfriend he won't eat it but he'll
eat eggs and ketchup and I'm like eat it
but it'll eat eggs and ketchup
yes I'm gonna come over and kick him in
the face yes you
kick his ass well that's like I don't
like when breakfast meals have equaled
the guy who in it but I like the guy
but I like ketchup I like me some
ketchup honestly you have the taste buds
of an eight year old it's like did you
ever put ketchup on green beans you know
that's something I do when I was eight
come on white rice green bean drop the
ketchup Jess yeah hmm I'm trying to
think of like if a guy cooked for me
like that would just I cooking for me is
a double-edged sword because I need you
to be helpless
I don't white like I cook let me cut
yeah I don't want the guy to be all the
wrong that's all the wrong man can cook
that's great yeah I relate to that
because in Casey and I first started
dating and he slept over for the first
time I'm like I'm gonna make him
breakfast and I hate the [ __ ] kitchen
I hate it so much but I just wanted to
feel like I was taking the mastic yeah
ladies y'all do not have to do that [ __ ]
you know I don't want now I don't but
yeah and then okay so you were talking
about things that really turn you on and
you brought up like bring doing a hobby
and stuff yeah Casey were on our first
date we ended up going back to his
apartment cuz I'm easy
and we've all been there yeah and then
so he started playing the guitar for me
and he was singing for the guitar guitar
got obsessed or I said the basic I mean
you guys beat me because as I was saying
this in my head I was like I'm gonna
start off by saying I know I'm basic
yeah it's like this and this and this
but I forgot that part
yes I realized I'm a basic ass [ __ ] but
that [ __ ] worked on me I was like but
you were a lot younger at the time I
feel like now if you were say if
something happened on alternate life and
you got divorced and a guy without a
guitar you would be like Oh
lame no but you know what I mean yes
it's lame but I guess I was able I think
I would be able to see past how lame it
is and just see the the intention the
presentation maybe yeah cuz the way he
did it too was like um he we were just
looking at stuff in his room he had a
whole bunch of movies we're trying to
pick out a movie to watch and then
that's when you bust out the guitar like
are you gonna play the guitar
cuz I took lessons there's like a B and
C of getting into a girl's pants
my ex-boyfriend an electric guitar with
no amp and play the no effect song and I
was like damn I'm wet with like teenager
tip yeah I was I got I signed up to
guitar lessons but then as a punishment
I got got him taken away so I never got
to learn I think it was Matt where I'm
like but you do know how to play
everything he knows how to play the
piano too I feel that way with piano if
I see you guys play out ya know I might
get insider you could read music like I
feel like talents are talking because
even when a guy makes you laugh like
he's funny like that is that is kind of
like I go holla you know Jaime yeah you
might have good timing
elsewhere oh he understands read ahead
doesn't he just have to arrive well
oh no nice need her so yeah it's it's
50/50 it's a 50/50 split
yeah nice well yeah so I don't know I
guess I am basic but music talents has
he whipped out a guitar any time since
then
yeah time and every time he plays it
well you bought him one for Christmas I
did I bought him a new one because the
old one he had no longer like the string
was hooked up and it's a really old
guitar cuz he got it from his dad but
anyway every time he plays it now I'm
like so that's so cute cuz like I could
see like a little like window into the
soul cuz he's such an artist and that's
the only way he really expresses himself
is like through his editing or like
whenever he's like creating videos or
when he's like playing music and then
that's when I get to really look inside
cuz he's really closed off this is
really [ __ ] sentimental right now I
it's like you actually you could tell
that you love him as a person so that's
good to know sometimes I'm like what do
I like ten years there's gonna be times
where you're like do I love this
[ __ ] don't want to kill my you
have to grow together yeah cuz that
thing was in a 5-year relationship where
we grew apart and that was tough because
yes stuff because nothing went wrong it
was just like he went that way and I
grew that way mm-hmm that one's tough
like I try to make it always like a goal
that like my guy and I like I feel like
we're all I feel like we're always
walking hand-in-hand like as we're like
progressing through life and it might be
very conscious of that I mean you can
just so quickly like unknowingly start
growing apart but you're very conscious
of it yeah like you could literally be
living together and start going apart
you know and you're and it just starts
with oh I'm busy I'm busy you know this
is going on this is going on but like
just as long as you make an effort to
come back together even if it's for a
few hours a few days you know every
month I think that that date night is
really important like yeah you guys
weekly date night yeah and not just like
alright it's date and I guess I'll leave
the house it's like you get ready like
you show up for that person you court
each other still like you're still
trying to impress each other you're just
trying to smell nice you're still trying
to be like whoo I hope they like me
tonight I think that's really important
to keep yeah just to keep that like
dating energy alive yeah that spark
because when I kiss him it still feels
like butterflies fill me like everything
is the same if not better than it was
like when we first started dating but
that definitely took work it wasn't just
like oh you know you found the person
and now like you're set forever you
don't have to do anything like no it's
it is whether people do get it's
maintenance it's it's that upkeep of
like really putting in the effort and
having both parties put in the effort
and checking in with each other making
sure you are growing together and it
helps that he's in the same field as me
where we work together a lot we have a
lot of mutual friends because that I've
seen that happen to where one partner
works in a completely different industry
and maybe they have to move and then
they have now like you get to move the
whole family or like you decide if
you're gonna move with them or not
yeah the checking-in part is really
important because whenever Casey and I
like our lives get crazy like for
example recently we just moved so like
we haven't really made that time to do
our nightly check-ins that we said we
would and when we don't we start like
distancing a little bit where we're like
we're not on the same page yeah thinking
one thing then the other person is
thinking another thing and then there's
miscommunication checking in is like so
important dude you know I think kind of
what I'm hearing like overall when we go
back to talking about our relationships
or people we've really loved and then
getting back to the conversation where
we're talking more about like hot guys
it's almost like they're the main
difference between like attraction of
just like I want to [ __ ] that and like I
love this person is just like the
attraction part is so much more
primitive yes it's very primitive it's
like we're not thinking it's like we
just our brains young teeny tiny and
we're just like yes [ __ ] time yeah and
then when it comes to love like we're
really thinking about it and feeling it
and processing it so much and sure not
all of the emotions are 100% positive
like there's negative and positive and
emotions that are intertwined in love
but with attraction it's just one solid
happy emotion which is horny I mean you
don't even really probably know that
person you know nothing about them
you're just creating also you're kind of
creating the desire in yourself and just
projecting it onto them and there's
there's no depth to it and I think
that's also why there's no satisfaction
from like kind of a one-night stand it's
not sustainable at all whereas love is
like I feel like I'm getting so corny
with this but love has so many different
types of emotions good and bad that it's
exciting it's enticing like it keeps you
it keeps you going and like all I know
stands just not gonna do that yeah
that's a pole it's like it's over it's
also like with a one-night stand it like
you're just attracted right but if they
do something annoying you're like oh I'm
turned off right whereas love it's like
you're with those annoying things you're
with their flaws and you accept all of
it you're like I'm in love with the
whole picture not just this part of you
I'm in love with all of it yeah even
when you're when you're angry yeah like
I could still choose you
exactly exactly well that that is the
step so for the week
look we've been getting lots comments
lots of I think we need more reviews if
you have not reviewed yet please drop us
review but more importantly share this
with the girls share this with the boys
bring in some more well I was gonna say
[ __ ] bring in some more moods bring
you some more moves
yeah and also I'm not quite sure exactly
when this is gonna premiere but either
our new youtube series is out or it is
coming out make sure you check that out
we're very very very excited at
subscribe so you don't miss it yeah and
be on the lookout whether that video
came out last week or if they're coming
out coming out this week might be coming
out this week also may see this know
it'll be coming out like this week as
this airs yeah okay watch all of the
episodes just in case that came out dude
look on YouTube know what our producers
are doing with this footage just look
come back I had so much fun on that
sleepover night oh yeah I would love to
do yes we need like an actual house we
need like a big mood house we do alright
guys we'll see you next week good bye